- Wait, one of the times
that we saw each other,
we were at a lunch and you were talking
about your son and how he's a musician,
you were so proud of him.
'Cause there's big footsteps.
- Yes, yes.
- With his father, Eddie.
So, it's amazing he's
nominated for a Grammy.
(Valerie shouting excitedly)
Congratulations!
- Oh, thank you, thank you.
I couldn't be more happy.
I am so much more happy for his success
than I ever, ever could be for mine.
I'm over the moon.
- [Kelly] Yeah, that's a mom.
- Yeah, I guess so.
- How did you get the news
that he'd been nominated?
- I didn't realize the
nominations were happening
and it was online and I went,
"Oh my god! I wanna see."
I saw Billie Eilish, and she
was announcing the rock group.
And when they got to best song,
I screamed in the middle of
my bathroom all by myself.
Scared my animals, they all
came running out of the room.
But, the first person I wanted to call,
after Wolfie, was Ed, 'cause
Ed was beyond the moon.
Proud of Wolfie, the only thing
in this world that ever
made Wolfie happy--
that ever made Ed happy,
they're the same person,
was Wolfie.
- [Kelly] Aw!
- Ed just got so much joy
out of watching Wolfie
play music and be creative.
I wish he was here.
- Well, and also, 'cause it's one
of those things when
it's something you love
and you see, even when I see my daughter
at a school performance, I'm like--
I'm not the mom that's like,
"Make your smile, honey!"
I'm not that mom, but I do get excited
'cause it's something that
we share, so that's cool.
- [Valerie] It is.
- I'm so happy for him, please
tell him congratulations.
- Thank you, I will.
- That's so frickin' cool.
Especially songwriting, that's so cool.
- 'Cause you know how hard
it is to write a song!
- It is, and it's also a hard category,
there's so many amazing songs
that are released in a year
and how do you pick the few
that are gonna be in that,
you know what I'm saying?
It's a hard thing, so, congratulations.